Not only can we use our SNVs to
connect ourselves and our families to populations all
over the world, but we can even connect
to one of our extinct relatives. Homo Sapiens Sapiens
us, to Homo Sapiens Neaderthalensis. This is a
close but extinct species. Neanderthals evolved outside of
Africa, and existed along a geographic range that
covered Europe through parts of the middle east and
central Asia, and using nothing more than
a DNA sample from Neandertal bones over
30,000 years old. A first draft of
the Neandertal genome project was published in May
2010. Since this report has been published, new research has suggested
that Neanderthals and humans actually interbred with
each other in Mesopotamia. A region in the Middle East about
50 to 100,000 years ago. New research
indicates that Neandertal chromosome regions were identified
in European and Asian genomes, but not
in African genomes, which was expected based
on the geographies of Neandertal fossils. Amazingly.
Looking at the SNVs shared between humans
and neanderthals, we can estimate roughly what
percentage of your genome might be carrying
genetic information that was once part of the
neanderthal genome. So even though neanderthals are now extinct,
they left relics of themselves in our own
genomes through possible interbreeding. And on the 23andMe website,
they actually have an ancestry tool to discover
what percentage of your genome has neanderthal variation. So,
here I'm showing you mine. I'm about 2.7%
neanderthal. I'm in the 56th percentile, and they even
have a little comparison here for you
to see, essentially, how modern humans compare to
neanderthals. Now it's important to remember, this
is kind of speculative and it's an estimation
based on the current data. And as new data comes in, these values may be
reassessed. And we may change how we
think about the human in the neanderthal relationship.